I know East Asians love they love
Pirates of the Caribbean maybe it was
marketed wrong
but Sebastian in the Forefront you know
I don't know they're just like dude I'm
hungry
they thought this was a [__] Netflix
Netflix food documentary a chef's table
I just thought it was like a mukbang
yeah oh this Smart Box a little in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast back with my reoccurring
co-host Ed Park VP my friends last week
well it was two weeks before this
I did a solo podcast because I [__]
forgot I I miscalculated the amount of
time that I was gone and like how many
episodes I had in the bag left and so
literally the day before I just was like
okay I'm just gonna talk to the camera
by myself for half an hour and that was
hard dude would you have pulled
something else out of the bag like
here's a podcast from six months ago I
didn't realize there's there's a few but
I can't release those yeah yeah there's
like there's the one with I still had
the podcast with that one uh porn star
that tried to [__] you know blackmail
me and [__] you want to hear something
[__] funny so she that girl
she met somebody that we mutually know
right and he came up to me he was like
hey do you know this girl I'm like who
but I don't actually know her name right
he didn't know her real name yeah I
didn't know her [__] real name and
I'm forgetting what her Alias is because
we never got that far to the podcast
before she started breaking down and
crying about having like a manic
depressive episode and I already told
him about this girl specifically in the
past when it happened because I was just
pissed right because of what she was
trying to do it was [__] terrible a
terrible human being and so he's like
laughing and he goes do you know what
she said to me she goes
oh I was like I'm not sure if you know
who I am but I I know your friend David
so and then he's like oh how do you know
him
he's like oh he's mean he made me cry
that's what she said he's a meanie he
made me cry I'm like you [__] [__]
you psychotic [__] I could literally
ruin your I could release that [__] and
ruin your whole [__] life try to
Blackmail me did I make you cry or did
you have an episode exactly it was the
weird when he mentioned her but I I
don't remember what her name was but I
remember I started sweating right
because that was one of the most
probably I'd say like in entertainment
why is the most traumatizing experience
ever especially because at the time the
metoo movement was so strong even if
that and I had all the evidence out
people still wouldn't have cared at that
time because people were so crazy right
and so she was ready to falsely meet to
you well she was trying to do it but
then obviously she messaged all my close
friends or whatever right in the
entertainment space and she started
spinning this whole narrative and they
all just blocked her because you know
we're all close they're like like no way
David David out of all people Please
block right you know right and they
messaged me and they told me I was like
hey do you know this girl like she's
saying crazy [__] I was like bro and I
showed them the clip of for like the
crazy stuff and so I have it saved in a
hard drive just in case yeah
because I have hold hard evidence of
that [__] and then uh if you guys
remember the podcast after even after
this whole thing and I said hey you know
what like this is this is not cool or
whatever I forgot what the conversation
was and then she goes hey let's run it
back and let's do another podcast
I'm trying to extort you
yeah and then our other friend was like
yes okay we're I specifically remember
her saying that she goes yeah don't
worry about it this time it's gonna be
so much better because I'm all about my
money oh god what the [__] are you what
are you selling yeah what are you saying
you [__] crazy you're gonna be like
oh she's on the grind all right let's do
this cry time she's an independent woman
all right let's do it it was it was
probably one of the weirdest experiences
ever man um
when I was like in Japan like the only
sense of like social media I had like I
feel like there's like this obligation
that I do some social media here and
there I just like tweeted a few things
just random [__] thoughts because I
literally don't care anymore like
there's no need for political
correctness I don't know where this
personal career mine is gonna go yeah I
have this podcast I enjoy it but um
there's this guy that uh popped up on my
feed and you know I went into a little
dive like oh this guy does like food
reviews let me see
and I didn't like his food reviews at
all but then he put He put out this
video saying that I went to LA and La
has no good food whatsoever yikes as a
food critic
right I was like what I'll say is this a
[__] joke that's what I kind of
tweeted I was like hey this guy and he's
a nice dude by the way I actually don't
dislike him at all there's nothing to
dislike about anybody who does food
reviews right you just disagree with
what they do because their job is to
critique things and give an opinion so I
feel like it's completely okay for me to
give a rebuttal uh like a rebuttal or
opinion about the stuff that he does
right because yeah yeah essentially
that's what he does for a living right
so it's completely fine and I tweeted I
was like yeah I don't think I really
like like this guy's food reviews just
basic as [__] you know he's very
particular only about the food that he
likes and he also said there's no good
food in La which is ridiculous for a
food critic right and like a majority of
people agree but there's a small site
they're like this is a l tag you don't
even know him blah blah he goes he's
just giving his opinion I'm like yeah
that's what he's supposed to do as a
food critic give his opinion and then I
as a person outside who watches his
content also give my opinion so what's
the need to have to defend a Critic I
don't understand yeah it's like you're
not
you're not like stopping him from giving
his exactly I didn't say he was a bad
person it's not anything like that I
just like I disagree with this stuff but
then what I found out was this
he blew up because he uh shed light onto
like a failing business and then they
blew up and they got to uh basically get
a leg up again because of him so he has
like this positive aura about it right I
wasn't a part of that [__] wave yeah
I don't know and so the other people who
agree with me they don't know about this
backstory so people kind of fell in love
with him because of this philanthropy
that he was a part of right right I just
know him for just food reviews and food
critiques which I'm pretty sure that's
what he wants you know what I mean and
so when I was trying to figure out like
am I saying something super out of
pocket and then a fan explained to me is
like oh he blew up because he did this
super positive thing oh so anybody
anybody who critiques him they're just
gonna come after you so it doesn't
matter it's like most people agree with
this but they just won't say it right
I'm like oh I see what it is like I get
it a hundred percent you know what I
mean and then somebody responded back to
me they go like how could you [__]
attack about attack him I wasn't
attacking him I was just giving you my
opinion about his food reviews you know
yeah man I mean people just look at
you know these celebrities or whoever
the [__] they are on this
two-dimensional space in the palm of
their hand and they [__] worship them
yeah so like can you can you guys not do
the funniest thing this person wrote
they're like how can you bully him like
he's on the Spectrum and I was like I
was like hey guess what surprise [__]
me too
yeah Spectrum who got the best Wi-Fi
let's go
it's a spectrum battle let's go you
better defend the [__] out of me too man
I'm high on the Spectrum [__]
yeah yeah different takes different
waves bro that's what we should do yeah
food reviews
because I like the guy I was like oh
he's like really very soft-spoken and
really kind I just like hey I just don't
like his food reviews like I just don't
think they offer anything but I found
out too he's you know Kevin Lee from the
UFC yeah yeah that's his brother
okay so his brother does food reviews
yeah his brother does food reviews oh
okay well I was like oh that's pretty
[__] cool and I wasn't making an
opinion about him as a person I just
wrote like a little comment like you
can't say just a blanket if statement
like La is has no good food for me it
was shocking as somebody who is uh who I
thought was a food critic like a
self-proclaimed food critic to come to
Los Angeles there's absolutely no good
food here right which is insane and I
say that as somebody I'm not from Los
Angeles right because what are the other
comments oh everybody who's upset is
from Los Angeles nah I'm not from L.A
I'm just saying like anybody who enjoys
good food people around the world go to
Los Angeles to eat food around the world
yeah
God [__] name are you talking about
La has no good food like I said that's
his opinion that's perfectly fine I'm
just saying for a food critic to say
that blew my mind you know so I'm like
oh that doesn't make sense to me that's
kind of like how
um
okay this is a messed up situation so
Chef Roy Choi he had this uh restaurant
open up in South Central L.A like in the
hood and he'd hire the kids in the
neighborhood to learn how to work and
how to get a job and how to make a
resume it was just a neighborhood
project it was doing good things this
guy from The New York Times got on a
[__] airplane flew to L.A you know
took a got a ride down to his restaurant
South Central L.A ate the food wrote the
shittiest review ever he said this food
is [__] terrible got that gun
airplane he's back in New York
God damn and the New York Times
published this article [__] on Chef
Roy Choice Hood now here we go
I'm not a fan of his food as as a person
who's tried out many of his different
establishments but then it's like
the the
fact that it's a project like this
entrepreneurial project this
neighborhood like project to help people
and then he just tells everybody in the
whole world hey this food [__] sucks
and everyone took a [__] on that food
critic like duh is that what you're
supposed to do as a food critic
it's like okay that's like you going to
the homeless shelter
it's like
do your time review for the soup kitchen
and [__] it
oh my gosh
but I feel like that's how people were
treating me I was like oh it's like dude
he's on another level of Yelp reviewers
that's actually pretty funny for uh I
would love for somebody to just do a
food reviews of soup kitchens kitchens
that would be [__] hilarious send
Foods episode out of dog
there's an [__] out there that wants
to do [__] food reviews of soup
kitchens you should [__] do it I
don't have the heart to do it yeah but
if you're [__] like on the spectrum
of nothing then [__]
could God be with you dude oh God that's
what I felt like people were mad at me
about so I really had to do a deep dive
I'm like did I say something crazy here
right yeah and it was because of that
one thing that he did that people have
an emotional tie to him but did dog I
got a couple of messages where people
were saying like hey this is an LT and
then I got DMS after saying like I
actually agree with you but we can't say
that right
so oh I'm not crazy so there has to be a
sort of if they got a fan explained it
to me so I'm like okay I get it is this
the activist side of the woke culture
and on Twitter then I think I don't know
what because it has nothing to do with
let's say wokeness but then he's is
doing a good philanthropic Topic thing
right it's not like you're [__] on
that and I think it's that in part with
him being open about him being on the
Spectrum which is so unfair because so
am I okay but how come you guys are
crapping on me
I may look all put together because it's
a struggle every day hey well yeah we
come in different shapes and sizes man
so I was I was kind of like
taking it back a little bit by it
because I didn't understand but people
have to understand that after that video
there was new people that came to see
him and they don't know about that stuff
they're just seeing the food critiques
and they're just like oh this is all the
same [__] and that's all that it is okay
weird right and I would love for him to
come to LA and I would love to
personally take him around to Los
Angeles we're talking about Los Angeles
I'm not talking about fancy restaurants
fancy restaurants no matter where you go
it's going to be good yeah they get the
best ingredients they have the best
chefs some of the greatest Minds right
but we're talking about Los Angeles just
like every other place too that's in a
small town has great hole in the walls
that have been institutions for here for
like 60 70 years 100 years 100 years
even right you go to Little Tokyo uh you
go out to East L.A let's talk about the
Mexican food alone yeah you know El
Cholo spot in K-Town you established
1920 dude crazy it's still there exactly
you can go to Koreatown let's talk about
Korean food but these are the type of
foods that I guarantee that he would eat
and he'd be like this isn't good because
the I once again like the I the the
response that I got for the people who
didn't like what I said was he's just
saying his opinion I'm like that's
literally the dumbest response because
of course he's just saying his opinion
he's a full critic
what are you talking about
like it's it's redundant you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah
it's like I watched it if you're not
supposed to critique a critiquer oh
you're not supposed to feel a certain
way about what somebody does for a
living even though his job is
essentially what I'm doing okay ask the
same people this like um get out 99 on
Rotten Tomatoes I went I was so curious
I read that one percent guy that wrote
that negative review and it's another
black dude right
and he called it a
um he called get out a
um
basically runaway Whitey movie for white
people to be scared of black people oh
wow yeah and then you so you look into
this guy and he's like he's a
black Republican nationalist you know
very right-wing guy and he just writes
these
um contrarian reviews
and so that was the only reason why it's
ridiculous he didn't get a hundred
percent right that's hilarious as those
saying tell the same people that hey you
can't be mad at that that's just his
opinion bro even though this guy clearly
has a [__] motive yeah yeah yeah [__]
on something 100 and by the way like I
said I actually like him because he I
like the way he does his video is super
calm so I I like the vibe of his videos
I just don't like his food reviews that
much do you feel like the way you're
responding to him people feel and it's
like a level of empathy like you might
make him melt down
I feel like they feel like I'm punching
down or something right right but then I
saw his page he has way more followers
than me I'm punching up yeah
what are you talking about I'm punching
the [__] up he's popping dude he's
popping yeah you're the one with social
Aspergers yeah where's my sympathy I
mean social media yeah yeah
social media responsibility but yeah
like I would love for him to come to Los
Angeles and for me to just get around a
bunch of my chef buddies and I know a
lot of people have uh hole in the wall
spots and just show them like Los
Angeles and the places that he ate at
were like chains I'm like dog this is
what I mean
foreign
Jersey Mike's bro yeah
you know give it a fair Shake first like
I said there's no animosity whatever I
like to eat a lot
I just want to him to come here on me
and I'll take you to Great hole in the
wall spots it's just you
and also too by the way like if he is
from New Jersey I don't know I've gone
to New Jersey multiple times I have
family out there I Googled what is New
Jersey known for for food the Google
search came back New Jersey is not known
for good food
that's all Google said that is what is
what Google said
the the diet like diners is where
um Jersey is where diners were created
after right but that was it so even
Google searches roasting Jersey right so
I don't want to hear any any Slanders
talk about Los Angeles food scene
because I do believe it's amazing here
yeah right New York Chicago Houston uh
and anywhere that you go the food scene
is going to be pretty good if you can
find it because you know South Carolina
North Carolina they kind of might be you
know where I went was kind of in the
boonies but there was always a dope ass
[__] uh barbecue spot yeah a rib spot
and
honestly outbeat 80 of the barbecue
spots out in California but everything
around it wasn't that great there's
always something from where you go but
to say that Los Angeles has no good food
whatsoever I in my eyes made me go oh I
don't need to look at your food reviews
you know and I think that's what it was
for a lot of people who saw him after
the the heart string content that he
made like I said like the dude a lot I
would love for him Keith if you ever see
this most likely you're probably not
you're way above me but I would love to
take you around Los Angeles and show you
some good [__] food food that you
like not even the food that you probably
will think is gross I'm talking about
the food that you generally like I'll
take you to spots out here and you'll
[__] love it Jesus Christ man so
Japan though yeah
what was it what was this trip for you
know Japan was like a honeymoon trip
okay but uh Japan was super cool I guess
this is my this is my third time going
right and I think I might bring burial
on here to talk about how to travel to
Japan in the most comfortable way right
because she handled everything she is
the spreadsheet person she's the person
that organizes everything from head to
toe because obviously I can't get my
[__] together at all
um there are a few things that this time
around like because I've been there so
many times now I got to see it with a
less
um
less biased perspective in terms of the
first time I went there I was so amazed
by everything and same thing with the
second time this time I was there for
two weeks it was a little bit too long
for me and I got to see things for what
it is so one of the things that I
noticed in Japan is like
everybody who is making content in Japan
that's from the United States UK
wherever the [__] that they're at they
are literally going to the same list
that everybody is blogging about and
then putting into their Instagram reel
Shibuya Shinjuku and
and all the food spots that they're
showing it's just the same things over
and over and over again and I'm like
when I went there there was like
I looked at these lists that had the
same places I'm talking about six or
seven websites so it's the same bloggers
that looked at somebody Alice's blog and
they just and they repeated it so I went
to like maybe me and Mary went to maybe
about three of them and they were
terrible the coffee spots that they
showed us was terrible the food spots I
I ate it I'm like this is like the most
basic version of this in Japan and mind
you we've been to Japan multiple times
Maryland lived in Japan so we were kind
of shocked like why is this here on the
list and what it is is that number one
they can't speak the language right
right the people who are making the list
that are obviously not locals this is
their first time going to Japan and they
just copy what somebody else did on the
blog
so I was very disappointed and it's just
like the social media age like they just
have to make content right so when they
say this stuff they go oh this is like
the best ramen in Japan how do you know
are you Japanese
yeah how the [__]
Tokyo has so many restaurants it's
unreal yeah I'm talking about it's such
a compact space every other store is a
[__] restaurant how do you know
[Laughter]
impossible so what we did is that we
asked friends and then we Pro tip by the
way if you guys do go to Japan you want
to find good food that locals know
Google the word in Japanese right and
then the Japanese Google searches will
come up and you you think [__] uh
American yelpers are vicious Japanese
yelpers are [__] vicious like every
tonkatsu spot that I was looking up
three stars
two and a half Stars 3.9 3.8 I'm like
damn do all these suck so there's just
no way anybody can have five stars well
four or five star at all right it's just
dead honesty dead honesty and I don't
know what their standard is yeah but I
ate at those three-star restaurants and
they were delicious I was like this is
[__] fat fantastic and that's how you
get around in Japan then you get you
look for the 100 but then it's Gotta
Have like 5 000 reviews on it like a lot
of people they don't review a lot either
so like I would say a restaurant with a
lot of reviews is like 200 reviews okay
but they don't really have that review
culture right I think that's a very
Western thing they go in they eat their
food if they like it they'll come back
that's about it they don't really need
to openly Place their opinion about
restaurants like that yeah which makes
it a little more difficult for people
like us when we travel to find good
places to eat the best stuff that I ate
there was stuff we found off of Google
right and then I'm like I should write
about this I forgot
I don't know where it's at yeah I forgot
where it was I don't know how to get
back there I ate there and I was like
this is the most delicious thing I ever
ate and I turned around and I was in a
different place
so everybody was asking like hey what
restaurant I was at I go I don't know
like I really don't know I didn't go off
these lists that you guys did right so
the best way to explore Japan is just to
go and if you see like a line with a
bunch of salary men there it's probably
going to be really good right if you see
there with a lot of uh like foreigners
it's probably not that good right here's
a great example
fish market right very famous everybody
goes there it is the biggest tourist
trap ever I just see a bunch of [__]
people from the US just like this is the
best food ever it's probably some not
all of them it's it's better than stuff
that you'll get in most places in the
United States yeah but they figured out
that it's now Instagram famous
they hijack the prices like five six x
oh my gosh ridiculous price I was
shocked so you walk in and you don't
actually see any locals there's no
actual Japanese people who rarely right
like it's all foreigners there and the
only people that are locals there are
like
honestly maybe I would say like 15 right
and they jacked up all the prices people
are eating everything and they're they
and literally down the street there's a
place serving it for like four times
less the price and they don't know
because they go this is the best food
experience if you've never been to Japan
I think you should go there but if you
already went there once you don't need
to go there again right right it's kind
of sad no man like
that
I think I
I have like an anti version of that
story you remember
yeah right so they they had they copied
Mr possum and they had spicy uh right
well it [__] blew up when was the one
next to Cafe Blue right it was just
packed but then noticeably it's packed
with a lot of um International Chinese
students right and then I guess they
their business did so well they opened
the second restaurant on Western and it
used to be a Sizzlers so a square oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's their second song right
now here's the weirdest part about it
the customer segregated themselves
really so the one on six is where all
the Chinese people go to and the one on
westerns where all the Koreans go to the
dirty Chinese
what the hell did we do
it just split up and they segregated
themselves it's the same exact food
though that's why I wonder if the prices
are the same that's hilarious they just
did it on their own yeah they opened two
locations and then the customers were
just like we'll go here and you guys
stay here yeah that kind of weird
um I mean we should probably talk about
this now just to preface this I didn't
watch The Little Mermaid right you
didn't watch it either right
yeah no I haven't seen it okay so
and I want to say this uh we've been
asked to do a review of The Little
Mermaid and I just can't get myself to
watch it because I'm racist no I'm
kidding no no no no the reason why is
because I don't like any live action
reiterations of 2D animated films yeah
um unless it goes straight on demand
we're not jumping out of our seats over
the animated version anyway exactly 1988
version like we don't give a [__] about
that I never had an attachment to The
Little Mermaid in the first place so
most likely why would I watch the live
action version of it
so I went to go see Beauty and the Beast
with my sister oh my God I went to watch
that with Mariel
Emma Watson can't sing dude right
why did they cast her bro yeah and so we
live we leave the [__] theater and
I'm clowning of it for all those reasons
if my sister got just [__] mad like
why are you [__] on yeah the [__]
like because she grew up loving Beauty
and the Beast so did I but not that way
I understand why she was mad at me but
like I didn't I I guess I had to see
like
like I didn't feel that way about it so
I was [__] on it that way so I the
ultimate end of the day thing was just
like then I don't feel like watching
Little Mermaid because I don't I didn't
care about the original one either
because we're only gonna see it for what
it is yeah right and I started looking
at some of the reading some of the
critic reviews which I rarely do before
I actually watch the film but I just
know I'm not going to see it I didn't
like Beauty and the Beast I watched
maybe 15 minutes of The Lion King I
thought it was [__] terrible uh
Aladdin was not good Aladdin was warhack
it was such a disappointment like we saw
the other ones and it's like you haven't
proven anything too exactly I looked at
the CG animation in the trailer for
Little Mermaid
not good and by the way this is a movie
set in the ocean after Avatar right how
how are we going to watch this and enjoy
this watching a crab with a Jamaican
accent that's an actual crab
it's just disgusting to look at with no
emotion in his face these two little
flappers
like yo I I I don't feel this that's the
same with the uh problem with Lion King
was that oh they didn't give these
animals eyebrows yeah no emotions or so
they had no emotions to emotion so weird
so the animals were talking but then no
they their faces weren't showing
anything out of it like these 2D
animated films with real creatures are
always going to look weird yeah right
this is by the way an opinion of an
adult watching this I think when kids
watch it it's gonna be a different feel
right especially if they didn't grow up
watching the 2D animated film I think
for kids it's [__] fantastic yeah
yeah uh they could watch it and they'll
enjoy it but I'm talking about for the
older adult audience that was already
introduced to it as a 2d animated right
and I go and I watch that and I'm like
this is kind of rough like I I just
don't have any interest in it
um we felt the same way with Milan yeah
oh yeah Mulan was another bust I mean
all of them I mean I think it's because
the Jungle Book did so well oh that's
right half of these killed it in the box
office despite the quality of what they
are they did yeah
so you can think I don't know this
current generation who just loves this
[__] from 20 30 years ago just want to
see a better version of it maybe that's
all George Lucas's fault because he like
redid the special effects of Star Wars
oh yeah yeah hey redo this too redo that
too so maybe we're asking for it there
was
um
a lot of backlash because apparently it
tanked in South Korea and also China
right and now there's a bunch of people
kind of digging up on the Internet of a
lot of racism like colorism like in Asia
saying like Asian people hate black
people right and you know this obviously
is in reflection that people start to
kind of mix two things together where
they now look at Asian Americans like
this is your people I'm like nobody
be American you know it's the same way
like white people will protest eating
dog in Chinatown America yeah like what
are you gonna do like what the [__] I
don't I don't understand why that
happens to Asian people so much like we
are Asian Americans we're different yeah
we're very very different and that's the
weird part about being Asian American we
don't actually belong [__] anywhere
we're not Asian enough over there and
we're not American enough here and so
we're just like these people without a
[__] land and by the way dude like
some Korean people said some horrendous
[__] they they brought up this old uh
picture of Halle Bailey and I think it
was a black pink member and it was these
comments from like Korean netizens and
you don't know how old these people are
they could be in their 40s their 50s or
whatever yeah and they were saying some
crazy racist [__] down
uh if you stay next to her for too long
that dark skin might rub off on you like
some horrendous [__] that [__] was
terrible and so you know they take these
little excerpts and they go this is all
of your people I'm like hold on a second
um and so they see like the box it took
it took a box office hit yeah in
um in South Korea right it didn't do
that well which for them it begs the
question like if this was a white Little
Mermaid wouldn't it have done better
maybe but then the other question you
could ask would be with the context of
The Little Mermaid story
the original one the 88 animation or
even the original Germanic story
whatever
do Eastern Asian people even have any
context about what this [__] story is
about I don't know should they care yeah
you know like I don't know you know what
I know East Asians love they love
Pirates of the Caribbean maybe it was
marketed wrong yeah
Sebastian in the Forefront you know I
don't know they're just like dude I'm
hungry
they thought this was a [__] Netflix
Netflix food documentary a chef's table
I just thought it was like a mukbang
yeah oh this Smoke Box a little weird
they're like when are they gonna [__]
eat this crap but that's it just goes
along with the stories like who you
always have to ask like who is this
movie for right yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then you just at the end of the day it's
for kids
and it's for for us it's easy for us to
look at The Little Mermaid and just
completely always compare it to that but
then you look at the way we reviewed
Mulan we reviewed it for what it is we
didn't say a goddamn thing about the
animated one right we didn't say a
goddamn thing about Mushu we're not
comparing it no we're just talking about
look at this for what it is as it is
right and For What Little Mermaid is is
for kids yeah you know so at the same
time if you didn't stress about it
nothing would change in your life yeah
because what is you stressing about it
100 nothing is happening in your life
either when I saw kind of you know just
the trailer for The Little Mermaid I'm
like oh this is literally a Kids film
Mulan didn't feel like it was a Kids
film this little mermaid feels like it's
for children like you're not gonna see
us dissect this episode of Sesame Street
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
I know who it's for I get it you know so
there's there's no point in us watching
it and doing like an in-depth review on
it I I just because I find it pointless
well then like
um the same reason why we don't have to
do an in-depth review of Super Mario
Brothers have you seen it yet yeah I did
see it yeah right and then you looked at
it's like how could it be that bad yeah
how could 50 of movie critics say is
that bad when it's like it's a [__]
kids movie this one was so people didn't
understand this thing I said this on the
um
the one critique that I had of it right
I enjoyed Super Mario because it hit my
Nostalgia points like a [__] it
was also very funny it was lighthearted
and it was great the the problem that I
had with it because it was a Kids film
was the message towards the end yeah it
was the one thing that I was actually
kind of laughing about because the movie
was about so you have these two brothers
who invested all their money and looking
for their parents approval doing the
right thing right and that and their dad
basically calls him a [__] loser
right and then he has to go ahead and
save the world get super powers and he
goes I guess I'm proud of you you know
I'm like that's kind of [__] up for
kids yeah that was the one flaw that I
found in it as a kids movie I'm like
that message is kind of weird they
didn't have to include Mario's Family at
all right which was like kind of a weird
like lesson to even tell if you could
have just cut it out entirely but then
the other
like um little message behind it was
like Mario's entire character trait was
not giving up right and that's the
essence of playing Mario Brothers is
like you [__] die all the time and
you just have to start difficult game
ever yeah it gets difficult but you
start over and over and over until you
beat it yeah like Super Mario Bros like
what are we going to review it's a kids
movie literally made for kids yeah there
are Disney animated like once again
Mulan that didn't seem like it was made
for kids it was made for an older yeah
audience and also there was
so much beneath the surface of Mulan
being this Chinese propaganda film that
I I just had to expose it yeah you know
a little mermaid too on top of the
controversy of just you know the
what do you call it Coastal racism yeah
yeah right on the on the east side of
the world that was a big issue there was
people that were upset that they were
abolishing Caribbean slavery that it
wasn't a point that was being made
yeah dude [__] look that [__] up
right now it says just put in Caribbean
slavery and Little Mermaid
and it was
the hottest topic it was the next thing
that little mermaid was being critiqued
about I'm like bro can this movie Just
Breathe for a second can they just
people just watch it first before you go
ahead and start [__] on it I want
the top hit is from Fox News the
headline says Little Mermaid remain
condemned for erasing slavery in the
Caribbean like I'm sorry in this Kids
film where did you expect them to insert
that part yeah
like she just makes friends with this
little slave girl and like what wants to
offer her voice to her I mean what word
what do you do yeah I don't understand
yeah like I don't understand like this
movie has gotten this goes to show that
you can literally complain about
anything it doesn't [__] matter
like that was the most ridiculous [__]
I've ever heard of my [__] life like
okay here's here's somewhere that's
actually worthy of a complaint
if you do you remember that Mel Gibson
movie about the Revolutionary War yeah
Patriot yeah so it was like Braveheart
but America right
in the beginning of the film
this guy will get some characters done
very well for himself right
he's got a lot of Black Folk on his
property
and they're gonna ask him like the
British revolutioners sorry
the British come to them and they're
like hey
let's stand up against this Revolt right
stay British we'll set you guys free
slavery is already illegal in Britain
and then the black characters go we're
free men here we're here on our own
willingly
this is about the founding of America
that movie erases slavery what the [__]
it's supposed to be like this historical
film no sir I'm happy being a slave yeah
[Applause]
oh that's hilarious but now we want to
talk about The Little Mermaid being a
problem it's like hey man like you guys
are 20 years too late on that [__] it's
just like they're not doing that that's
why they're not bringing it up I
guarantee when they were doing this
rewrite and then putting it into the
Caribbean they were never going to
expect that to be one of the harshest
critiques that they were going to
receive that they erased slavery so when
they say you're raised I mean I didn't
read the whole article is it because you
don't see slaves I don't know like I
don't I once again we didn't watch the
film so maybe we're kind of casting
Stones when we really shouldn't be right
but I just it's a it's a kid it's a
[__] mermaid yeah it's a half fish
half person and then all of a sudden we
go into the 12 years of slave story and
then like and then we jump back into
this mermaid stories yeah where do you
fit that with the talking crab the
talking fish and then a talking bird
what are you talking about
I don't understand this like the only I
think a film that Disney could really do
really well
um without making it corny having the
animals talk with their mouths obviously
[__] Pocahontas
um
I don't know man
I don't know I think Pocahontas because
it's you know John what's his name John
Smith John Smith was a real person
Pocahontas was a real person but the
real story is tragic yeah let's not do
that though yeah that's what I'm saying
I want the Colors of the Wind no no yeah
that's this thing because Pocahontas is
like historical revision it's like she's
she was kidnapped and raped so 16 year
old girl okay never mind guys yeah they
took under England forced to have white
babies around as like this
like exotic native and [__] she had a
horrible life afterwards okay I thought
the real story was this girl could talk
to deers and raccoons yeah and she had a
beautiful singing voice yeah she was hot
as hell that's the thing you can't
remake that I guess I think they're
skipping that and going straight to
Hercules okay Hercules would be good
would be good I love Greek mythology
yeah and the style that they have it in
like keep that up yeah keep that up that
would be [__] amazing yeah but then
like you can't
Force us to like [__] right okay so the
other thing is
you have to remember what Disney was for
us growing up right it was a girl's
product
oh yes right yeah yeah yeah in the 90s
80s Disney was always a girls product it
was always about the princesses and
stuff right being saved by the man yeah
so the boys like we even if I watched a
movie you didn't really give a [__]
about these princes like we did give a
[__] about like I guess Simba and
Aladdin until and then you got something
like Hercules right where there were
they had to cater more to the boys of
America right
then once they became this giant
conglomerate like what did they do they
bought [__] Marvel and Star Wars Star
Wars to get the boys to the Disney
conversation right
now here's the thing
they didn't boy up the Disney product
they curled up the Marvel products they
curled up Star Wars right I think that's
why you're getting a lot of that incel
noise from the boys being like Oh my
girl female leads like this was my Star
Wars this was my superhero whatever
right
and then but at the same time they're
always like looking at the boys like you
don't like Little Mermaid because you
don't like black people or you don't
like women and it's like wait no it's a
little mermaid yeah it's just not for us
it wasn't like marketed towards us it
wasn't nothing about that you know for
Me growing Up made me want to watch
Little Mermaid yeah I only watched a
Little Mermaid because I had to I was
forced to because there was other people
at the church that were girls that
wanted to watch Little Mermaids I didn't
want to watch that [__] did you have the
original VHS with the dicks my my cousin
does yeah my cousins
[__] dick VHS man there was like uh
an interesting conversation too when um
when it came to like the idea of a
Little Mermaid and you know people get
upset at Disney because the conversation
about that is that
Disney is just going to woke yeah right
so when they are replacing certain said
nostalgic 2D animation films with other
ethnicities or races like in this case
for a Little Mermaid it's with Hallie
Bailey
um they go oh you're now you're just
trying to be too woke uh I had to sit
there and think about this right because
in my mind it's what the [__] the
problem it's a mermaid
that's just not even real yeah what a
this is not a historical [__] film
yeah it's not real so I don't have an
issue with it right
and then it I have to start reading what
other people are thinking just to
understand the [__] pandemonium like
what is this about and it wasn't even
about a Nostalgia Factor they're a
majority of the people that were writing
their qualms with this whole situation
wasn't about them messing with something
that they love growing up which is what
I thought it was originally it was just
this is
Disney being so [__] woke that they
have to make everything about race right
so they don't even care in the first
place they don't care at all they just
care that there's a black person
they think it's like some kind of
political move yeah I don't know if it
is or not I just don't [__] care
every every seems like every like old
ass culture has some sea creature
mythology right I mean like the reason
why it's in the Caribbeans is because
the people of that area [__] migrated
down to curb Institute their pirate [__]
yeah they do their lawlessness or
whatever and they brought all those
mythologies down there and a hundred
percent sure now I'm not sure
but if there are crabs in [__] Norway
I'm 100 sure they don't got a Jamaican
accent yeah
hurry up
like I'm pretty sure that's not
happening either so I I don't really
agree with that either right one of the
things that maybe this is you know and I
was reading kind of uh what other people
were saying who were like black
Americans or you know from wherever
they're at
they said the one thing that they did
wish was that Disney would start
creating more black stories that aren't
changing the characters of already
stories that were written for white
people yeah like we don't want that yeah
like let them let [__] white people
have white white mermaid right give us
our own story like let's start making
new Disney animated films with real
black stories and real black characters
so we don't have to say that we don't
because it's like oh I couldn't kind of
see that too yeah you know but that's
not what people are saying if I I think
if that was the story I would understand
a little more yeah I mean if they gave
us like here's the thing like
the easiest thing that I could think of
like when we talk about let's talk
specifics with Asian Americans then
let's talk Korean superheroes right we
got teguki
here yeah and Amadeus Cho the Hulk right
I can understand that it is much easier
to tell us a Korean story as the Hulk
with the Han and the Ingress 100 you
know than it is to tell the teguki story
like like the captain Korea story yeah
um
but in any case
would you want
the next Iron Man to be korean-american
no I don't care no like what does that
even do for us at all yeah what's what's
this [__] Iron Man gonna do work at
Samsung
[Laughter]
just as a good ass airport yeah okay
they always take idea from my poem and
they put it in theirs for like three or
later he said nobody by the Sony I know
nobody by Sony anymore Japanese a phone
is a stupid wait for the Samsung
PlayStation they're [__] arch nemesis
is like LG and [__] like what the [__] I
don't need that so I do kind of see that
we need our own stories yeah I would
prefer that and there is actually going
to be a Disney animated film of an
original black character too I think
it's coming out in June okay yeah I mean
that's that it's what we need like in in
my heart of hearts too like
we we are seeing so much representation
for Asian Americans right but I'm saying
that blanket
like as a blanket statement because I
think I really mean Chinese American
there's so much Chinese American content
oh 100 but then they keep marketing
Asian American Asian American because
they want all of us to sit watch it
because it's Asian people but that's
what a lot of Asian Americans even do
here right where uh for example
somebody will say well how come you're
not going to this
they kind of just lump us all into one
without kind of recognizing our own
personal identities right because Korean
Chinese Japanese Indonesian Hmong
Malaysian Laos
all Thai all distinctly different
cultures yeah not even remotely [__]
close yeah you know what I mean but they
all kind of just lump us all into one
and I'm pretty sure a lot of people like
you wouldn't do that to European
countries no you know what I'm saying so
they even throw in you know Pacific
Islanders yeah Indonesian people and
they have their own distinct culture
Indian people have their own distinct
culture and so we all just always get
kind of tossed into one thing
um I did get a little there's this
comment that
kind of got under my skin a little bit
because this was an older older Asian
guy and I couldn't believe like what he
wrote because of how [__] dumb he is
he wrote this thing where I said on a on
a podcast with Tim I go it's like I
don't really need
um you know aapi months like that's it's
not my thing right I don't think I don't
personally need it and this guy was like
why do you always just say stupid [__]
just to say stupid [__] like why are you
why are you [__] on this Asian
American thing like I would have loved
to have that when I was a kid I was like
cool because you were a self-hating
agent I wasn't yeah
yeah I could say that I didn't need it
growing up yeah you know what I mean
because I was not the self-hating Asian
which is the reason why I started this
chat I'm not the reason why but I was
one of the few that started this Channel
and just was who I was you know yeah I I
wonder about that too I mean everyone
has their own story but I don't
understand where people feel like I need
someone I needed someone to tell me I
should have been proud of myself for
being Asian I'm like what
and I actually why did you that's that's
General curiosity I that I don't
understand on other humans why did you
need someone else to tell you to be
proud of who you why is that their
responsibility yeah and I I sat and I
thought about this right
um like why is it that this type of
person always exists like now like you I
if I had this I would have been PR I
think it's actually guilt they feel
guilty for denouncing their culture
their language their Heritage they're
now 40 years old they don't know their
[__] language they don't know where
they [__] came from they wear their
shoes in their house
to eat the ramen with the fork
they talk back to their parents they
call them mom and dad by their first
names Janine yeah you know so they
denounced their culture so much but then
when they were younger they're
projecting the stuff that they hated
about themselves onto like somebody like
me or somebody else because you and I
know some Gen X hungs who are almost
pushing 50 who was like that in the 90s
who was just like
you know needed to be accepted as as
damn near being white Yeah a hundred
percent and now they're doing the
opposite of like yeah more represent
more Representatives like listen chill
you know what I'm saying and so when I
don't share their sentiment and I said
actually I'm not a part of your group I
grew up very fortunately or maybe I was
just [__] crazy enough to I always
carried my culture on my back no matter
where the [__] I went even when I was
around people who weren't Korean or they
weren't Asian right I was Korean first
always I never [__] hid my food uh I
only hit my food because my dad told me
not to because he told me it was gonna
stink but I was the kid that brought
kimchi fried rice to school yeah I
didn't give a [__] with somebody else
thought so I don't share your sentiment
I'm not saying what you're feeling is
wrong but for you to tell me that I I
feel like a aapi month doesn't do
anything for me because I always carried
my ethnicity on my back why are you mad
at me for right you should be proud of
me you have other reasons to have a chip
on your shoulder
meanwhile there are people out there who
are using their Asian identity as the
chip on themselves yeah their shoulder
like and you gotta understand like
you gotta let that go like you gotta let
that go also being Asian being your
downfall you gotta let that go also you
know all I'm also a part of the Asian
Community are you beating on me fool
yeah what's up bro why you beating on me
oh where are those people to [__]
defend you I know but you forget I'm
dude I'm the original Gucci fool yeah
like I was out here doing [__] when you
weren't saying [__] at all so as much as
I I never talk about the [__] that I do
nobody ever gets to say anything about
me about supporting Asian [__] at all
yeah I am a [__] four founder God
founder in this space when it comes to
that stuff you got your first viral
start because you were [__] on a
racist white exactly like when it was
not cool to do this I was doing it and I
got [__] on I got verbally bashed in
these comments and none of you said
anything none of you were creating
content with me none of you came to this
shows with me none of you came to these
speeches none of you they said you were
saying what I feel yeah I thought they
gave you props for because you had the
guts to say exactly so the idea that now
that this 40 year old man mid-30s
whatever is coming out and saying hey
and by the way it's not a big deal I'm
just I I'm gonna be honest I I just
couldn't figure out what this guy was
saying yeah you know it's like why why
do you have to say that you don't need
aapi month like why can't I I'm also a
part of the Asian Community I can have
my say in this Morgan Freeman says he
that there shouldn't be a Black History
Month he's allowed to have that pool
allow him to just like all right mister
like yeah like they they disagree but
they're not gonna like like what are you
gonna get out of him by asking that
anyway like also two just to kind of get
people to understand my perspective on
that for me personally I never looked at
Asians as lesser than in this country
yeah I never did I never shared your
sentiment up with that and you never
felt like I never felt it either because
and my dad always put it to me in the
best way possible he goes I you know
when I was a kid I remember when
customers would come in and they were
like verbally abuse my dad it wasn't a
lot of them like I said I'm only talking
about like the two percent five percent
of customers that would do this and my
dad I specifically remember my dad I'm
like why don't you say some [__] dude
like you should say something he goes
why I'm like what do you mean why he
goes because he goes listen when
somebody says racist things to me and
says terrible things about like my dad's
laughing and saying that they speak to
me in Korean he goes do you ever see a
like do you you always see a dog bark at
the Moon do you ever see the moon how
about how back at the dog
[Music]
um
because why hmm it's pointless people
who talk about me like that are beneath
me you know what I'm saying so he goes
where he goes I'm a business owner I
came to the country and I now own a
business it was hard I didn't know the
[__] language I worked [__] five
six jobs and I somehow made it out here
where I'm still barely speak English and
like I'm we're not rich but we get by
but I did this
with my own effort it's so funny the
analogy your dad game gave you is such a
Korean immigrant because it's very
similar to Tywin Lannister about a lion
not concerning himself with the opinions
of a sheep yeah yeah the real doesn't
have lions
yeah does the dog Bark at the Moon
you know
and so like for me I never thought of
like Asian people that I I thought we
killed it silently like we did it by
accumulating wealth by owning businesses
and then sending kids to college and our
you know a lot of Asian American kids we
even had the statistics for we're the
ones that go to college we're the ones
that go to Ivy League colleges to UCS to
to universities all across the nation
yeah so there was no point for me to be
like okay Asian people aren't killing it
if you thought that that's on you that's
not on me yeah so that's my perspective
of like I never understood I know I do
understand is what I'm saying I do
understand why people enjoy and they
like aapi month I don't need a whole
month for that that's my existence yeah
so it just doesn't resonate with me like
that yeah I mean I live in K-Town it's
aapi all day every day every day
it's whatever but you know for people
out there who are in different parts
like you know when you were out in
Seattle out in the boonies it's for them
I get it it's for you but I should be
allowed say hey I don't really need it I
think really it's for public schools
yeah Public Schools there's that kid out
there that might need it they want that
recognition for it right but I I in
general don't like identity politics
yeah and that kind of feeds into that so
I'm not maybe that's why I'm not a big
fan of it there's probably a little more
thinking that I have to do into it but
when people tell me oh it's aapi month
it doesn't mean [__] to me yeah it
doesn't make me happier doesn't make me
sadder I just go oh that's cool that's
it I mean it was like At first like when
I was aware of aapis because
um you know when you scroll through a
Comcast menu yeah yeah
um they'll be like their own ads and
[__] and they would just run K-pop and
I'm like what the [__] this is long ass
time ago it's like it's aapi month so I
never heard of that yeah and I was like
oh [__] that's cool right and well that
was like 13 years ago but look what's
happened
um since PSY and since Big Bang since 21
since every single K-pop artist that's
just hit it big here in the states it's
like k-pop's just on the radio yeah it's
just there it's like it doesn't they
don't have to put it on because it's a
certain month you know and also too
sometimes I feel and I wonder if other
people feel this way too I feel with a
lot of Asian Americans when they tried
to do Asian American Social Justice we
never try to figure out our own way of
doing things we always just try to
piggyback off of like Black Culture
white culture it's like how about we
develop our own identity here yeah like
they go oh you know
black Americans have this we should have
no no no let black Americans have what
they have yeah right and let's create
what we have yeah and sometimes I just
feel a little confused about that type
of stuff I just don't also like people
dictating how I should feel about my
culture like how I feel about it it's so
weird and they say that you're the one
with the problem with internalized
racism it's because you don't like being
Asian that's why you don't support it
like I've gotten that accusation
which is crazy yeah I mean
so it was because of a
you know a q a like when when I had lost
100 pounds I just got a million
questions all the time and so I did this
kind of q a thing and then it was like
it was a joke right I wrote the pros and
cons of of losing weight and it was I
said that
um
more white people Latina people and
black people hit on me they come and
talk to me now right and then I got
I got attacked by a bunch of Asian
Collins college students saying that I
have
internalized racism because I don't want
to date Asian girls that's not what you
said but that's not what I said right I
was making the point that like yo like
in this day and age I'm getting hit on
by more people of different races not
just Asians you know that's something
new to me because I went to high school
and had a white blonde girl tell me in
my face that I am the ugliest guy in
school yeah you know I've had I've lived
in that day and age when white people
just say you have a flat face your
pancake face
I should kick you in the back of the
head so your face comes out God damn are
they telling me that [__] yeah yeah dude
you know like I lived in that day and
age where like I got [__] hate crimes
right yeah but then I'm having these
[__] college kids tell me
all this woke [__] like I like and they
will never experience what they're so
scared of well this is what I'm saying
this
that's the weird part right they are
inherently hating the stuff that they
see in themselves you are the
self-hating agent for you to go out of
your way and bring another Asian person
down and you have created this narrative
that wasn't there yeah it's so weird
also objection yeah projection and I
also dislike sometimes and you know what
I gotta say this too because I was once
you you know like I really was and you
know when you get older hopefully you'll
snap out of it too and I empathize with
you a lot because when you're younger
you get angry about [__] everything
and you want to complain about [__] and
speak for other people when you haven't
experienced those experiences yourself
you're scared about things that has not
happened to you you live in this state
of fear with experiences that you have
not [__] experienced right and so you
don't really you get to but you don't
get to say that to somebody who has
experienced that type of stuff you don't
live in that [__] world yeah you know
what I'm saying like for somebody to go
out of the way and be like well you have
internalized racism blah blah blah and
you don't know what it's like it's like
no no you don't know what it's like yeah
you actually don't you literally don't
know what it's like like the situations
I've been in like and the responses I've
had to make were always just split
second it was do or die you know and
what I know is most of these kids would
have no [__] clue of what to do in
the situations I've been in like one
time in school
so I told you that there were other
Asian kids but they're all adopted yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so they all have
white parents well there's this huge
Ruckus and like Ruckus In the hallways
right what the [__] is going on and this
dude is in this adopted Korean girl's
face right and so I walk up like oh what
the [__] and I'm right there and he goes
get the [__] out of my face you [__]
[__] right and I froze
I froze
and she froze and everyone's like oh
everyone's looking at me and I froze and
he walked away
and I was so ashamed of myself
yeah so the next time
same grade year too because hey who
think this would happen twice in a year
some [__] call me a [__] again
in that hallway and I [__] I gave it
to my [__] socks in the face I've
never done it before in my life it's
sock them and I made sure my everybody
saw
and now I had the reputation Don't Call
Him a goo yeah right because I didn't do
something before they felt empowered to
say to me again so I [__] socked them
and then they I never was called that
again you know that was a thing too when
you know like when you stand up for
yourself and you kind of make it hard
for somebody to bully you it it it kind
of stops not all the time right and I
think you know I thought you were gonna
say was like the next year I saw him and
I was like that's racist yeah
and he's just like what are you talking
about bro
I've been thinking about that in the
shower all my life
in a whole year
[__] like you know what are you gonna do
that kid ended up being expelled anyway
and I never saw him again yeah you know
but that's also because my friend was
there like he took a [__] lunch tray
and broke it over his head God damn
kicked the [__] out of him I was on the
ground
that's the thing too man when we look
back at these situations and you know
we've said it on this podcast a million
times over like you should never have to
beat yourself up about that because it's
never happened to you before for the
first time for the for the first time it
happened yeah you don't know how to
react you don't know how your body's
gonna react you don't know what you're
going to do or say and I'm like I said I
told this story a million times over
I've said like hey if I see something
bad [__] go down and I see somebody in
trouble someone's getting robbed I'll
probably step in no they didn't I
watched it go down right in front of
that Jamba Juice in South Pasadena and I
saw them ride away with the bike yeah
and I [__] 20 minutes later hey you
know it's just you don't know what's
going on you're always this like hero in
your head yeah and you know the you know
the reality is is you're you big
yourself up a lot more than you actually
uh than the person that you actually are
yeah and I think that we do that in
those uncomfortable situations but at
least like the second time around you
[__] did something about it and but
you gotta understand then there's like a
million other Asian Americans then
someone called them a [__] someone says
something on the road and they froze and
that person just wrote off and then they
just have been living with that
for years okay [__] you know I mean like
the [__] that happened in New Orleans oh
yeah that's right I couldn't process it
because I've never been called that
before but I was I was ready because I
have been my whole life yeah right I was
holding your Sony oh does it was the A3
yeah I was holding that camera and I had
a cigarette in the other
I just I throw [__] when I mean yeah
[__] it was like
through the cigarette but I was like
and he drove off and I was just like so
[__] angry I remember I said I was
like what do you say yeah because I I
couldn't you know process it I was like
what do you say and I think the part
that defused it for me the most was like
the people that were next to us and like
he's a [__] [__] don't worry about
it yeah and so because that wasn't the
the general consensus was that this was
wrong and other people around like that
[__] guy's an [__] yeah I felt a
lot better because there any new or
anything like that like that guy's an
[__] yeah they just didn't want us to
walk away with the bad impression
because everyone else was [__]
awesome to us yeah dude they were all
chill and they're just like yeah don't
[__] worry he's a [__] [__] I'm
like Oh okay that's cool
um yeah it was just really hard to
process because I didn't feel like he
was in a beat-up truck too
The Stereotype was just too hard
like God damn it I forgot about that
[__] dude I was in New Orleans that was
[__] weird that day yeah and like I
said that's why I understand why a lot
of kids out there they probably need the
aapi month because they don't grow up in
an environment where you know being
Asian is something that's looked at as
positive yeah so like I said it could be
for those kids in like St Louis you know
Kansas City yeah maybe they need it too
so okay well so I look back at I
understand why he's upset I just think
it's weird that he's upset that I have
an opinion about my own asianism that I
feel like I don't need it like why are
you putting yourself into my [__]
shoes right Express how you feel about
it and then Express that you needed it
growing up but because you like you know
what we said before I had to think about
it you are upset at me because you
probably wish you did what I did when I
was younger you know where I said stuff
like I spoke up about [__] but back I
fought back you never did your dignity
yeah and so the only one that can take
my dignity away is myself yeah damn
right you cannot make a clown out of me
and so now for him it's like instead of
going ahead and saying the stuff that
you wanted to say at those people you're
saying it to me now yeah like which is a
projection yeah tough guy like you're
saying it to your Asian Brethren you
should have said it to that other person
you should have been the kid out there
that yeah you didn't erase your [__]
culture you learned the [__] language
you know you should have been that
person but you weren't don't put that on
me that's not my responsibility I'm
Gucci all the way dude
we know who we are we're scaring who we
are and we know all of our flaws too
yeah you know we don't hide that that's
I mean the that's the very idea too like
um have you seen a lot since the I mean
it is pride month
like people ask well then like why why
do they have to be so proud right like
there's no hetero pride month or
whatever right because we're the norm
it's a norm like what's the percentage
90 of the population yeah you've never
been told to be ashamed of yourself for
who you are right black people
historically have been told to be
ashamed simply because of the color of
their skin you know and a lot of people
for their cultures and their histories
which is why there are months and days
to celebrate them because you know with
St Patrick's Day yeah Irish people were
[__] on for a long time yeah I feel like
maybe with Italian Americans they want
to keep Columbus Day because it's all
they got yeah
but the rest of the world is like [__]
Christopher Columbus yeah yeah yeah but
I understand why you'd fight but yeah
[__] them you know yeah that's I I did
read a lot about that online you know
especially because I'm on Twitter people
are complaining about pride month and
stuff like we don't I always hear that
argument we don't have a straight month
is it because we don't need it it's like
the majority of us out there yeah so we
weren't like in a press group or
anything like that so for them to be
able to kind of show their happiness out
in public in the most extravagant way
possible is the opposite side of the
spectrum of them having to hide it their
whole lives because they're afraid of
getting beat up having people say that
they were possessed by [__] demons
you know what I'm saying doing exorcisms
on them going through uh sexual
retraining like come on man it's it's a
pretty simple concept you know what I
mean like you may not like it right it
makes you uncomfortable or some [__]
fine that's whatever but for you say you
don't understand it that's pretty
[__] dumb yeah you know I mean even
the way it's categorized too with like
when people say aapi they're still
thinking East Asian people yeah yeah yes
so you know I've told you before about
this Rabbi friend of mine he was like
you know because he's Jewish he's like
hey man I'm Asian too no one says Jews
are Asian but like we are West Asia you
know
I need something but nobody says that
but we consider us Eastern like Judaism
is an Eastern ideology you know Central
Asia it's all Arabic it's all Muslim
it's India it's all about Russia is Asia
too I'm almost here where you put your
shoes first yeah
where the [__] did you put your shoes if
you took it out before you in the house
maybe but you know is this is America so
it's just this kind of clownish
representation of who we are it's just
you know this East Asian look so that's
another thing like with Native Americans
right should Pacific Islanders be lumped
in with natives instead then or are they
native Asians like I don't know well
this is where it gets all muddled you
know and I think now we're so into once
again the you know I talked about
identity politics like people are so
focused on their identity and kind of
basing their whole life and culture off
of this identity it's weird to me that's
another thing isn't identity politics
putting yourself in a box yeah
strategorizing yourself yeah you want a
check box that's why you want to check
something that represents you on a
government piece of paper yeah like this
is who I am because of this there are
things that we could paint homage to
that we love but there are more things
outside of just what you look like the
color of your skin I mean I thought
that's like the Martin Luther King tip I
thought that's what we were going for
yeah but now people actually this box
that I feel like Martin Luther King and
a lot of people uh you know let's say
even Malcolm X like we were trying to
push ourselves out of this box people
like no no I feel more comfortable if
you categorize me like don't look at the
of my ability don't look at my talents
don't look at the things that I do see
what the color of my skin is first
before you talk to me and I'm like this
seems a little basketball backwards ass
backwards dude
like I can't stand I mean we said it
before like
because of what woke has become
right what was woke originally right it
was the idea of recognizing the
struggles of the oppressed people in our
country and Bill Burr made that joke but
very poignant real fact that
types of white people whether they be
white gay people or white women stepped
in front of the line of Oppression
took over what woke meant and now it
became more first world problems anyways
guys that wraps up this episode of The
Genius brain podcast uh hope you guys
enjoyed that episode uh you can catch
senior Sprint every Sundays at 12 p.m
and you can catch Ed at edpark VP and
Bible study at Momos uh see you all next
time peace peace